my talk at the table is how weather has  actually led to a shortage of hot sauce  the california company says that it  makes a very popular brand of sriracha i  don't know about you guys but i like a  little whatever on my sriracha sauce  the drought in mexico has affected the  chili pepper production there and if  they can't get the ingredients they  can't make the sauce hai phong food says  it has temporarily halted sriracha  production and the shortage could last  through the summer and you've got some  with you got the last remaining  everybody's gonna like chase you down to  get it pass over that garlic chili sauce  right now  don't tempt me thank you very much